ravens at the patriots some of the back
and forth some of the bouquets thrown by
in between a couple of former mvps in
lamar jackson and cam newton
man my boy lamar got a gear not many
human beings got game recognized game
you know he the og
superman
for him to be as successful and to make
the impact the big splash in in in this
game you know not many people
have done it you know i say michael vick
i say lamar
you know i you know i don't even think
i'm in that in that in that stratosphere
i watched cam since uh armor you know um
everyone in the country did everyone
know about cam superman you know doing
doing this thing you know um and a lot
of us looked up to him um he's a mobile
quarterback um he do his thing he's he's
a person who has who has took this
this league by storm
and especially you know early on the
doubt that came with it i mean i i we
all can relate to you know being
a second guest question can he play he
got bus written all over him and things
like that and for him to succeed through
it all
you know makes him the true underdog
story that we all love to root for
joining the program now someone who
spent 14 seasons in the national
football league now with nbc sports
boston former patriots and other team
quarterbacks matt castle matt what's up
buddy how are you man
good to be on the program i'm doing
great
good good good to have you welcome to
the family sort of we're all under the
nbc sports umbrella so we appreciate you
very much and it's great to have it's
great to be talking to a quarterback who
actually knows what he's talking about i
talk to one four days a week who i'm
convinced doesn't know what he's talking
about and chris sims it's good to have
somebody with me who i can who actually
you know won some games and spent some
time in the league and uh anyway it is
great to have you and i love chris i say
that about chris i'd say to his face i
love chris but uh you're part of it part
of us now too and it's great to have you
matt oh i appreciate it yeah i'm happy
to be on and you guys have a lot of good
banter going back and forth i listen to
you guys all the time it's pretty funny
listen to you guys give each other crap
all the time it's great i love it yeah
we
we appreciate that okay so sunday
night's game raven's patriots not the
cachet that it would have had in past
years because the patriots don't have
that sizzle what's the game plan what's
the rabbit out of the hat that bill
belichick is going to have to come up
with to beat a ravens team that on paper
is clearly better than the patriots
right now
right obviously offensively they've got
their work cut out for him against a
really good
ravens defense and it starts for for the
patriots offense it starts with this
offensive line isaiah win joe tooney
david andrews jack mason these guys have
been playing well throughout the course
of year now they've had some injuries
that they've had to deal with to rotate
these guys but then when they they've
got their full stable of running backs
and it starts right now with damian
harris who's really emerged as kind of
their go-to guy who was a little bit
banged up last week we'll see if he can
go but rex burkhead sony michelle's
supposed to be back james white that's
really the nucleus and the strength of
this offensive unit so they've got to
set the tone in the run game because
when you go outside and this is where
the mismatch really happens in this team
i mean for this team offensively is is
the weapons on the outside to complement
that run game and right now jacoby myers
has emerged over these last few weeks
which has been pretty incredible i mean
he's got 22 receptions in three games
where the guy really didn't even suit up
early on the year because of injuries to
julian edelman nikhil harry and so he's
finally got his opportunity he really
played well last week but then from
there you got the mirror bird you
haven't had a lot of production at the
tight end position so they've got a
tough task especially going up against
the defense when you look at their
secondary with the ravens with marlin
humphreys and these guys i mean they're
they're a good group and they're going
to pressure them and they're going to
get after them so they've got to
you know get going with that run and
then at the same time be able to set up
the play action
and we've seen the patriots defense matt
struggle with the run just a couple of
weeks ago blown off the field by the san
francisco 49ers and we've seen what the
ravens can do 265 yards against
pittsburgh just a couple of weeks ago
between lamar jackson gus edwards jk
dobbins
is there a way that that bill belichick
can can coach guys that may just not be
physically suited to to handling that
kind of a rushing attack and and slow
down what the ravens do best
uh you summed it up right there i mean
49ers went for 197 buffalo bills went
for 190 they've struggled stopping the
run and really it comes down to
personnel so far this year obviously we
know about the opt-outs we know about
the losses in free agency with van noy
and jamie collins and danny sheldon and
these guys but at the same time their
personnel group has primarily been in
nickel which is not a big personnel
group from a run stopping front where
you normally would see the patriots in a
3-4 defense with loaded box with big
stout guys hightower obviously opted out
but now you're talking about a group
where adrian phillips is really a
primary linebacker which he's normally
in the safety position and it's a very
difficult offense in terms of going up
against the baltimore ravens the
physicality that they bring they're
usually in a lot of 22 personnel when i
say 22 personnel i mean two tight ends
two backs in the backfield sometimes
they're in three tight end sets and then
the way that they set up their offense
the great job that greg roman does in
the different looks the pre-stat snap
motions all the different movements the
pulling guards the misdirection the rpos
it's really difficult to prepare for
something like that and then not only
that but in terms of the physicality
that they bring i just don't know if the
new england patriots can sustain and and
will be able to go out there and just
out physical them because right now they
just don't have the depth on the
defensive line at the linebacker
position particularly with joe quan
bentley being out lawrence guy was out
last week who's really their best run
stopper and if those guys aren't back
it's going to be a tough tough order to
say the least
matt you could look at this game and
wonder why in the world isn't the
headline lamar versus cam we played the
sound earlier about those two praising
each other
cam doesn't have the sizzle at this
point that maybe we thought he was going
to have a couple of months into the
season what does he need to do to get
back on that track that it felt like he
was on before he tested positive for
covet 19.
right you know what it's one of those
interesting parts i mean every season
has ebbs and flows but this one has been
just a dramatic change you know like you
said dolphins and the seahawks game you
had a great promising outings like
you're sitting there going this could be
the cam newton of old he's really
starting to grow and then covet hit
right after that raiders game he missed
the chiefs games came back against the
broncos they struggled a lot and some of
that was due to the offensive line and
the the issues that they had with you
know moving parts and all that stuff
with guys being injured and out because
of covid related stuff but then 49ers
was by far his worst game he struggled
he was benched in the third quarter
three interceptions and they weren't
just interceptions they were bad
interceptions and everybody starts to
question and wonder can this guy do it
and then all of a sudden these last two
weeks really is where you can start to
see progress and he's starting to get
back to the player that we saw early on
and
between the bills and the jets he was 40
for 57 for 234 no tds but three rushing
tds and no interception so if he can
continue that trend and continue to work
and take care of the football which that
was the biggest issue in the middle of
season was him
turning over the ball and playing
reckless at that quarterback position if
he can take care of the football put his
team in a good position throw the ball
accurately let the run game speak for
itself and then let some of the
athleticism take over when he's running
the ball then he'll be in a good
position and he'll help this football
team
matt we all have our crosses to bear
professionally i have to work with chris
sims you have to work with tom curran
bill belichick has to answer questions
from time to time from tom curran here's
an exchange from earlier today between
curran and belichick let's listen to it
and then we'll talk about it on the
other side
you have any idea
why you've had a harder time getting
consistent production
and development from the guys that
you've selected in the draft
well let's say each
look any time you bring a player onto
your team you
[Music]
put them into
a role or
a situation that you think fits him
sometimes you have to modify that a
little bit as you get to know the player
and then you work work with them to try
to develop that so the most important
thing to me is winning games and
um
i'm not going to apologize for our
record over the last 20 years i mean a
lot worse
so ultimately try to put the best team
on the field that we can to
be competitive and
i don't really see that changing
tom curran tried one more time to get
bill belichick to address the failure to
develop draft picks in recent years
before belichick finally said i'm only
focused on the ravens this week after
talking about it for five minutes then
he says i'm only focused on the ravens
this week matt what's your assessment of
this disconnect between
draft picks
development
and who's ultimately contributing now
because you need that nucleus of guys
who have been going through the pipeline
over the years to rise up and be the
heart and soul of your team and it feels
like the patriots don't have that right
now
right it's really been since jamie
collins was drafted i believe in 2013
was a really last pro bowl selection and
if you even go to the wide receiver
position which we talked about
consistently they've had production
there but it's really guys that they've
brought in since 2010 and the draft
picks that they've had i don't think
that those guys have accumulated more
than like 1500 yards receiving in in
that entire tenure of the last 10 years
of guys that's been drafted since 2010
so there's there's definitely some
misses and and you can't you have to
build a nucleus within the draft because
you only get so many guys every single
year and there there's a lot of question
marks going on right now about their
draft picks why they've done certain
things why in 2000 going into the 2018
season when lamar was on the board and
some of these other guys why didn't they
take a quarterback at that point because
tom was getting older they knew
inevitably that he was probably going to
move on you know there's all these
discussion points and so
you know the the thing that bill points
to is yes
he's always got that trump card right he
always could say well i'm not i'm not
too concerned considering my record over
the last 20 years but now he's lost his
franchise quarterback they're in a
rebuilding stage right now and this is
where when you lose a guy like tom brady
who kind of can
can cover up a lot of those
inconsistencies that you might have at
other positions now it's starting to
show its head a little bit and you start
to question okay well where were those
draft picks and why aren't we producing
like other some of these other
organizations are
hey i i agree with you matt when in
doubt just flash the rings that's all
you got to do you know what slash
he's a two-hander i mean he's got drinks
whatever i mean let's be honest it's not
like it's one hand you have to see in
one finger you're sticking up you're
sticking up like six i mean my goodness
you've gotta you've got an argument
there
hey real quick real quick since you
played with tom brady and he's now with
a new team and he's trying to get number
seven down in tampa what do you think
needs to change there for that team
after they got splattered on sunday
night
right well you know when you watch that
game on saturday night it was all about
protection and and to start the game
they came out and they went i believe
their first four series were all three
and outs and you can't start a game like
that against the saints the division
rival who knows you and if you get
behind the ball then they basically
they got away from running the ball with
ronald jones they got away from running
it at all really and they were stuck
trying to throw the ball and sometimes
you know having all that weapon it's a
all those weapons it's a luxury but at
the same time you're trying to figure
out okay who am i going to get the ball
to and everybody needs to get the ball
distributed to them and it's sometimes
hard i would think as a play caller to
try to figure out and create plays to
design to go to all these different
weapons and not be have a one focal
point right and it's a it's a great
problem to have at the same time they
got to get back on board with running
the ball they got to stay ahead on down
and distance they got to get into
manageable third downs because if you
don't do that in this league the the
pass rush is too good and the guys can
come after you and it's real hard on any
quarterbacks particularly tom brady when
he he's a pocket passer you know i mean
you've got to protect the pocket and if
they know you got to pass they're going
to pin their ears back and they're going
to come after you
matt excellent stuff let's do it again
real soon all the best to you and the
folks at nbc sports boston and thanks
for some of your time pal
absolutely mike have a great one buddy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports